I'm here with Jeffrey Moore author of
crossing the caching the chasm and other
ultra famous business books that we've
all read at one point in our life and
what are we going to talk about we're to
talk about writing we're going to talk
about writing from the point of view of
a writer and we're going to talk about
writing from the point of view of a
reader hmm and how is that different
well so the writer is trying to express
themselves and the reader is trying to
either inform or entertain themselves
the to connect but but if you realize
you're actually starting from like San
Francisco and Marin and trying to build
the Golden Gate Bridge because the
writer really does have a strong need to
sort of express their identity or act in
the world from some intention they have
and that is not necessarily immediately
aligned with the reader the reader has
their own strategic intentions and and
they're typically related either to
something more pragmatic like I need to
get informed or something more personal
I want to be entertained or enlightened
many times I've read something where I
felt that the writer was not aligned
with my with my priorities I much of
writing is like much of life you know if
you could if you can align with your
with you the world the world will
actually bring you in and when you find
the world it's not bringing you in it is
often because you have not bothered to
align with it all right right right
right and so within these contexts what
is there a different way of thinking
about writing or what writing is or yes
so if you're a writer you want to think
about writing as a process it's a
creative process and we we've developed
some frameworks and models around seven
steps of it but it's like it this is
while you I mean people don't know other
than being an ultra famous business book
writer you are a writing professor I was
I I taught writing for for ten years and
in the process of that developed a set
of frameworks to help not only myself
write but the professors at the college
where I was teaching help them also
organize their teaching of writing and
so that's where all this work Ridgid was
originated and basically the the first
piece of it was to distinguish between
grading themes which is what the
professor's first thought
which is actually about writing as a
product and that's what readers care
right the reader experience is the
product and they're you and you can you
can talk about various aspects of the
product and say that there have you know
a quality be quality see quality or
monkeying or whatever and we'll talk a
bunch about that under product but what
students cared about was writing as a
process how could they better express
themselves how could they be more
successful in the world and so the
process models tended to be around an
arc of creation from sort of invention
through to publishing mmm-hmm and the
product models were more around a set of
values that are very traditional they go
all the way back to the Greeks and
Romans and and the goal there was to
give them a model which says well how
many different aspects of this of good
writing do you have to understand in and
how do you focus to get mastery and so
this is example what would be an example
process well say so process might start
with was they often talk about
prewriting you you even step back and do
one I'll give you the seven steps we
talked about so the first one is
typically called assessing and that is
like what's the writing situation am I
writing a letter to my grandmother for
money
am i am I am i texting to a girlfriend
am i am i writing a theme for a
professor and basically the work that we
were doing was the freshman writing
requirement so the idea was this is
college level writing to help you in
your in your social sciences and liberal
arts work so assess the writing
situation so so what's the topic what is
my strategic intent is a writer who is
my putative reader who am I expecting to
read this then we go into an invention
mode and the invention mode is a very
freewheeling thing and personal styles
are so different that when different
people invent you know some people are
very structured in the way they like to
go after this some people are very
unstructured some people like to
procrastinate some people like to plan
ahead I mean it's it's all different
styles so the invention but so we had a
series of frameworks saying depending on
your style you might try this one or
this one or that one and and eventually
you won't find somebody to find one that
they say okay that feels like me and
would you say I mean everyone's got a
different process but in general you're
saying inventions when you're finally
like you're putting something down not
necessarily writing necessarily some
people might so they might actually
start writing
some people might outline some people
might jot notes exactly
people normally call that prewriting and
if you just literally start writing
immediately they often call that free
writing because you're not you don't
really quite know where you're going
right the invent when you go from invent
to organize the key transition as you
pull out of the invention material
however you've put it on the paper some
key sentences that you're saying okay
this these are the key points that in my
and you're typically writing an essay in
the freshman in the in college English
requirement so in my essay I'm gonna
make these points and we often call them
the thesis sentence which is the sort of
the overall point of the essay and topic
sentences which were the points of of
just each paragraph in organizing is
about getting those sentences in the
right relationship to each other and
figuring out how much how much support
each of these claims is going to need
and stuff like that and then you go to
drafting and you actually write you
write the middle paragraphs you write a
conclusion you go back and write an
introduction and you're essentially
turning it into words that that are now
intended to be read so now at this point
it's almost like I'm talking to you
right now I'm trying to be understood
I'm trying to figure out what's going on
but it's still extemporaneous you're
still making mistakes you're still going
back and say I didn't really say that
quite right and so just an example I'm
you know and once again this is very
particular different people everyone
could have a completely different
process but this is at least an example
of one invent you can write you might
write down some words outline organize
you start to take the bullet points in
your outline and structure them say hey
these would these would kind of support
one paragraph right over here let's
let's throw those together because
they're all putting back to the point
about why I should get paid more or
whatever whatever it should be and then
draft is the first time you after you
try to write sentences year I think
that's right if anybody uses software
from Microsoft organized looks a lot
more like PowerPoint alright draft looks
a lot more like word I see I sort of
that's kind of where we are but but it's
word before I've done spellcheck right
okay so drafting is just a cut at the
end of the draft what you'd like to say
is somewhere on the page I've gotten
most of my ideas out and at least from
my memory of writing papers and in
school this is once you're done with the
draft phase or kind of your stress goes
down wait way down we've got something
wait
even if you know it's not good good
enough now in fact the people that
struggle the most with writing are the
ones that won't let themselves write a
bad draft right and I'm excellent at
writing a bad read no trouble with
actually that turns out to be a huge
skill because if you can write a bad
draft then you or other people can help
you during the next stage we call the
review stage right and in the review
stage you know you can improve now the
difference between what I went to school
and and the current curriculums is huge
and I think it's terrific when I went to
school you'd you review you had to
review and edit your own work and there
was never anybody else involved that's
extremely difficult and frankly not a
very good idea it's far better to have
your your work pre peer-reviewed and so
the best writing instruction now uses
peer review groups typically two or
three or four people in a pod and they
read each other's drafts and they give
them they give each other feedback about
it and you have to learn among other
things that protocol when they and the
sort of the decorum of getting feedback
like you can't just say your writing
side exactly your writing sex they give
up that's sort of the Bill Gates style
but that's not always like no he's not
no he's a very kind man now but he was
very when he was doing if it was
software I heard story he was pretty
clear that's the dumbest thing I've ever
you know but the truth is at the margin
better to get true feedback with bad
style
all right then to get false feedback
with a grin and that's what we say here
at Khan Academy before we do reviews we
say feedback as a gift yeah it is a gift
sometimes it's not wrapped in the paper
you were hoping but but whatever it is
so then there's a review thing and then
you do the editing based on the review
and the editing and again with the world
of software now we have more editing
tools that help us so there is spell
checker there's style checker there's
there's stuff you that you can use it
during the editing thing that will help
you and then the final the final thing
is publishing and and we have wonderful
stuff for publishing now I mean we you
have you have all these gorgeous things
whether it's blog publishing with
WordPress or or or whether it's it's
just making something beautiful in Word
or even I think that's formatting
footnoting font selection for sure for
the college absolutely for the college
you there's a set of conventions how do
you do a bibliography how do you do how
do you do all that kind of stuff and
also I think just increasingly now
people are realizing the cosmetics of
presentation particularly now that we're
all in this consumer eyes dwelled and
it's a digital world it's kind of
unacceptable now set to not look pretty
good because there's all these tools to
make you look good all right now that
this is entry I mean and I emphasize you
know like the way I write I kind of go
into that free writing phase very
quickly but I I think I am implicitly
doing a lot of the the invent the I'm
kind of doing an outline although it
might be a little bit messier than what
a lot of folks would consider an outline
and I think you also are very thoughtful
in your assessment so you and I have
talked over the years and I think you're
starting going back to your nephew or
niece or their you're the first tutoring
you started with you were assessing
their situation and then you were
thinking about ways that you could
communicate and you and you actually
modified your medium or if I recall
correctly yes you you were in one medium
and you switched to another medium sink
to a sink revenge I got on YouTube and I
think that was all a response to us
assessing the writing situation and then
you're inventing now I'd be curious so
when you're gonna do a new topic how do
you did you how do you prepare the
material before you actually start the
the video session that's enjoy this is
this conversation about writing but
we're really just talk about
communicating with folks and and
obviously that's something that I hope
I'm doing a bit of and with with the
videos and you're right and and this is
what I tell a lot of people when they
want to make videos is I spend a ton of
time right over here you know I mean to
some degree is first some of the math
I'm gonna spend the last 12 years or 15
years or 20 years of my education
thinking about what's a way to distill
these concepts how what's an easier way
to communicate the these concepts when
I'm doing things like a history and I've
been doing a lot of history lately World
War one etc etc I spent a lot of time
assessing it one of the key ideas here
what are the things that really matter
for people to get the big picture and
then I do on the invention especially in
history just to I'm horrible at spelling
I kind of do write a couple of bullet
points and what I think are the big
ideas so if I'm like minute four into a
video I'm like oh you know I forgot to
talk about the Battle of Caporetto
that's the most important point of this
whole video let let me let me let let me
let it trigger my brain so I actually
you're right I do a lot on this side
more than I prom
we admit often yep and and actually a
reasonable bit right over here I think
so too and then what the other thing
that's kind of fun about your videos
from my point of view is you don't worry
too much about being on the bottom of
the bottom part of this hierarchy you're
willing to let the draft in fact have
it's a little bit like watching Julia
Child cook on television when she
dropped the turkey and then just had to
pick it up I think there's a sense of
like this is you know hey we're all of
this together it's a real world and and
so rather than get these artifacts which
are impeccable but a bit very distant
right into some areas so there's a fun I
guess what's the opposite of irony a
reinforcing thing here that we're doing
this in right now yeah what we've just
produced is kind of a kind of a draft
it's right it is interesting and and I
think I think the editing and the
reviewing and publishing is more just
going back and saying okay so this could
be just a little vignette conversation
with Jeff Moore and Sal Khan this could
say no I want it I'm gonna actually use
this in part of a structured curriculum
okay then you then you in the review
revise editing and publishing you start
thinking about well do I want to do I
want to break this into two parts doable
etc etc etc very cool well this is neat
we're already beyond the allotted ten
minutes which we tend to give ourselves
here at Khan Academy so let's talk about
the the reader side in the next video
okay sounds good